with rising inflation including record
high gas prices americans are the most
downcast about the u.s economy since the
start of the pandemic this according to
a new gallup poll but inflation isn't
all bad for everyone we connect with an
expert who explains
inflation remains top of mind for
consumers it's a broad increase in the
prices associated with a constant amount
of goods and services and is typically
referred to as a negative factor so who
does inflation hit the hardest
inflation is really bad for savers host
of afford anything podcast polapant says
retirees who keep most of their assets
in the form of cash suffer the worst but
on the other hand if you are a borrower
with a fixed interest rate then
inflation actually works in your favor
let's say you have a mortgage with a
three or four percent fixed rate loan
when inflation is above the interest
rate on your mortgage you pay back your
mortgage in cheaper and cheaper dollars
over time she says the same can be said
for anyone who has a student loan or car
loan any type of debt that has a fixed
interest rate
she adds inflation also works in favor
of people who own a lot of tangible
assets something like a house or a car
or even art or jewelry you know things
that are tangible goods
those things tend to hold their value
over time and so inflation could be good
for you or at least less bad for you
than somebody who has most of their
money in cash
she adds that inflation also removes the
risk of deflation that's when prices
fall as a result factories produce less
and are forced to lay off workers which
means unemployment rises in that case